on m'a déjà proposé sept cent mille
euros couasnon euros pour un week-end on
sait franchement valérie bénaïm oui
c'est qu'est-ce que vous connaissez ce
film proposition industrie où la mer m
s'est tous posé la question avec robert
redford progressant d'un million de
dollars pour passer une nuit avec des
mii moore vous est ce que si quelqu'un
vous propose un million de dollars pour
passer une nuit avec vous vous dites oui
oui mais dix balles c'est la moins chère
huawei cher vous faites déjà proposés
vous oui non oui déjà quelqu'un vous a
pas besoin d'argent position des 107
euros
ces trois formes et a déjà proposé de la
sérieuse mais oui oui saint aubin
parfois quand on rencontre des gens à
droite à gauche si vous proposent
parfois des choses bizarres mais ça m'a
amusé ça va flatter franchement pourquoi
mais vous l'a été non mais j'ai pensé
ah oui ça aurait été sympa dans vidéo
gag non mais vraiment j'ai pensé parce
que c'était c'était quand même c'est
flatteur au fond et ça vous prend aussi
pour une mauvaise idée à proposer quoi
oui mais je suis pas allé jusqu'à la
somme finale j'ai pas voulu demander
mais on me dit combien vous voulez vous
ça m'a plus à ma page sans plus à mama
m'excite je vote ben oui c'est vrai
c'est à dire que c'est pas tes attentes
si vous vous mariez c'est bien non
motogp mais là dont il a dû recomposer
un tajine couscous voulez quoi non mais
là par exemple robert redford tient pas
la route
ben ouais c'est vrai cette histoire ça
tient pas la route pour un million de
dollars ils sont beaux tous les deux et
c'est à elle elle va pour toucher avec
robert redford gratos c'est pas mal
c'est voilà quant à elle avec robert
alors fm entre soi surhumain vous faire
dépenser pas manger normalement plus bas
vous bon on m'a déjà proposé sept cent
mille euros dont 1 euro pour un week end
entier sur la côte d'azur avec un couple
et vous allez avec this kiss et les
jouets on m'avait envoyé la photo de la
femme qui est très jolie ouais on ten
blonde très joli j'ai pas vu la photo de
l'homme ce qu'il fait c'est le pôlin
s'il fallait faire un truc à trois noms
quelle célérité que je fasse un truc
avec le mari avant et après le semaine à
l'action j'ai dit non ils sont venus un
an plus tard proposant un million
je le dirai cette histoire est fausse
dans des échanges encore les échanges
libres dieu c'était un peu radin ça va
réunir cette somme il en proposa mido
est ce que vous avez est ce que vous
avez hésité j'ai hésité à un million
d'euros c'est meilleur j'ai vraiment
hésité et après je me suis dit qu'est ce
qu'un million après faut il faire un
truc j'ai pas envie de faire était pas
mis à l'époque un vrai conte ses frères
alors des fois on fait des trucs qu'on
n'a pas envie de faire sans être payé tu
es bête
merci merci si la compagnie soirée et
vous moi c'est récent des liens non sur
la côte d'azur
j'étais chez des amis et le téléphone
sonne et en fait c'était un russe je dis
pas non un russe qui avait vu que
j'étais sur la côte d'azur parce que
j'avais mon instagram et gym passe le
téléphone et me dit ma fille c'est son
anniversaire elle vous aime beaucoup je
précise qu'elle était majeure elle avait
22 ans et il m'a dit elle vous aime
beaucoup et il m'a proposé 25000 euros
pour venir le samedi soir chez lui et il
m'a dit peut-être un peu plus si vous
êtes très gentil avec ma fille non non
non
si j'y vois là mais il serait content
des champions alors moi je vous dis on
m'a jamais rien proposé pourquoi pas moi
jamais jamais moi y'a un truc qui se
passe on vous a proposé dix balles pour
les livres 110 mêmes bases et non moi
y'a un truc qui se passe depuis je suis
tout jeune c'est toujours dit combien on
me proposerait pour faire avec un homme
coach hétéro je me disais qu'à un
million je le fais non un million je le
fais mal
il ya un truc de ouf plus je vieillis
plus la somme à des sens